Пішоходи переходять дороги у недозволеному місці,
водії перевищують швидкість та ігнорують "зебри", а міська інфраструктура
не забезпечує достатній комфорт і безпеку учасникам дорожнього руху.
Як наслідок за 4 місяці цього року в Україні вже трапилося понад 45 тисяч ДТП,
з них більше 2000 - за участі пішоходів, це забрало 377 життів.
Ми приєднуємося до патрулювання поліцейськими одного зі спальних районів Києва,
аби зрозуміти, як часто та чому нехтують правилами дорожнього руху саме пішоходи.
На порушників не доводиться довго чекати.
Неквапливо і самовпевнено прямо перед патрульною машиною
чоловік перетинає 6-смуговий столичний проспект.
Поліцейські кажуть: такі порушення спостерігають щоденно.
Люди перебігають дорогу просто, де бачать.
Аргументують це тим, що їм просто лінь.
А от люди похилого віку, коли робиш їм зауваження, проводиш профілактичну бесіду,
прикро чути, як кажуть, що я тут 30 років ходила і ще 40 буду ходити.
А внаслідок цього трапляються доволі часто дорожньо-транспортні пригоди.
Місце, де ми доєдналися до чергування патрульних, не найжвавіше у Києві.
До того ж, поруч є обладнані наземний і підземний переходи.
Однак попри це вже за декілька хвилин проспект навпростець перебігає ще один чоловік.
І поки поліція повідомляє йому про порушення,
проїжджу частину у недозволеному місці долає його товариш.
Обоє свою поведінку на дорозі порушенням не вважають.
Уряд повинен спочатку навести порядок. Підземні переходи всі темні, обгиджені…
Давайте зараз спустимося...
На даний момент світлий час доби,
перша година дня,
сонце, не хмарно, дощу немає, туману немає.
І чому вам боятися?
- Та ніхто нічого не боїться.
- Ну, ви кажете, що там не освітлено.
Це взагалі не має ніякого відношення... Добре, далі є решульований пішохідний перехід.
За перетин вулиці у невстановленому місці поліцейські дають чоловікам попередження,
хоча могли накласти штраф - 51 гривню.
Якби порушники були у стані алкогольного сп’яніння, то заплатили б 136 гривень,
а спричинивши аварію - 170 грн.
Депутати Верховної Ради таке покарання вважають надто малим, тому
вже проголосували в першому читанні за підняття штрафів для пішоходів уп’ятеро.
Після повторного голосування розмір максимального штрафу може скласти 680 грн.
Співзасновниця Асоціації пішоходів України Поліна Павлюк
таке підняття вважає виправданим. Водночас, прогулюючись спальним районом,
у якому мешкає, звертає увагу на вкрай проблемні для пішоходів місця.
Даний пішоходний перехід є абсолютно типовим для Києва.
Це те, про що ми казали. Немає профарбованої зебри.
Я, наприклад, доросла людина, яка бачить і чує,
я перейду тут, це зрозуміло. Я тричі подивлюся на дорогу і перейду.
А що говорити про людину, яка похилого віку або, наприклад, не чує, або не бачить.
На сонці взагалі не видно, що тут є дорожня розмітка.
Якщо подивитися по колу, то тут всюди манекени яскраві.
Водії, на жаль, не реагують на цих манекенів.
За даними поліції, щотижня в Києві фіксують у середньому 10-20 наїздів на пішоходів.
Половина з них трапляється на пішохідних переходах.
Владислав Самойленко, який займається дослідженням міського простору, переконаний:
ані високі штрафи для пішоходів, ані законодавчі обмеження швидкості для водіїв
не здатні максимально гарантувати безпеку учасникам дорожнього руху.
Цього можна досягти, удосконалюючи міську інфраструктуру,
тому Владислав разом із колегами ініціював та реалізував за бюджетні кошти
створення так званих "антикишень",  тобто розширених в місці пішохідного переходу
тротуарів, а також підвищених наземних переходів та острівців безпеки.
Однак і цього замало. На прикладі одного торгово-розважального центру,
розташованого на проспекті з високою концентрацією ДТП у столиці,
Владислав показує, як інвестори й міська влада нехтують комфортом і безпекою пішоходів.
Ситуація притаманна насправді багатьом вулицям як Києва, так і інших міст України,
коли тротуари і переміщення людей стоїть на нижчих пріоритетах, ніж автомобільне сполучення.
Щоб потрапити на інший бік, людина долає майже кілометр,
щоб знайти зупинку громадського транспорту,
неочевидними маршрутами.
Тут проситься перехід на іншу сторону, можливо, навіть підземний,
шляхом тунелю. Він був би зручним для маломобільних груп населення і взагалі для пішоходів.
У цьому місці загинула вже не одна людина, в тому числі батько з сином,
коли, не знаючи, де знаходиться перехід, почали переходити 8-смугову автомагістраль.
У комунальному підприємстві "Центр організації дорожнього руху" небезпечні ділянки,
про які говорить Владислав, бачать на екрані моніторів.
Тут у режимі реального часу слідкують за всіма київськими світлофорами,
аналізують ситуацію на дорогах і за потреби ухвалюють рішення
про встановлення безпекових конструкцій.
Запевняють: роблять усе для пішоходів, однак ті не вирізняються дисципліною,
а тому мають ретельніше контролюватися поліцією.
Людина цікава. Не контролюєш - вона порушує.
Контролюєш - вона виконує правила дорожнього руху.
Правила мають виконуватися як пішоходом, так і водієм.
Що ми робимо в місті? Сьогодні я можу сказати,
це і зниження швидкості по пзш-установкам (примусове зниження швидкості),
огородження, яке не дає пішоходу перейти дорогу,
він іде по цьому огородженні до пішохідного переходу.
Це і знаки, які забороняють паркування там, де ми маємо пішохідний перехід.
Воно все є. Воно все виконується.
Віктор Черній каже, що Київ поволі стає більш пристосованим для пішоходів.
У центральній частині з'являються нові наземні переходи,
вулиці поступово реконструюються за сучасними нормами,
даючи людям більше простору. Однак і пішоходи, і урбаністи наполягають:
окремі якісні проекти дійсно є, але вони не дають масштабних змін,
адже в Києві понад 2000 вулиць.
Водночас нові інфраструктурні рішення для пішоходів,
як-от скляний міст вартістю майже 10 мільйонів доларів,
що з’єднав дві зелені зони у центрі столиці, мають радше іміджевий характер.
Тим часом, за даними поліції, минулого року в Києві
трапилося понад 700 ДТП за участю пішоходів.
В них загинули майже пів сотні людей.